the unity of the international community
is today more not less relevant than
ever the use of chemical weapons by
anyone anywhere must stop immediately it
must be no doubt that those responsible
for violations of international
humanitarian law or human rights
wherever they are whether they are will
be held accountable we committed to work
for sustainable inclusive peace while
addressing the urgent humanitarian needs
inside Syria and supporting the work for
neighboring countries in hosting over 5
million refugees the conference
recognized that humanitarian needs of
vulnerable people especially women and
children inside Syria and in the region
were never so great access for this aid
throughout the country has to be
improved and sieges and servation
tactics has to stop what Syrians needs
and wants is a political solution
negotiated between the Syrian parties on
the basis of relevant UN Security
Council resolutions only through a
genuine and inclusive political
transition will there be an end to the
conflict we therefore gave our full
support to the Geneva peace talks and
commended and encouraged the excellent
work of the UN Special Envoy Staffan de
Mistura investments of political work in
supporting a resolution to the crisis is
key in securing a future for Syria and
its people on the Syrians can make the
agreement that will secure peace but the
commitment of the international
community and the region is supporting
them in achieving that peaceful future
is essential sustainable and inclusive
peace in Syria for the Syrians remains
the objective of all our common work we
will continue to express our concrete
solidarity in action not just in words
delegations present here in Brussels
have a made a collective pledge of six
billion dollars
for this year alone thank you so much it
is an impressive figure